good afternoon my name is david mcneill
i'm a closure developer at uh on the
lana core orlano cloud
team at viasat and i'll be talking about
a
uh a library that we've built for
working with core async
code so
core async is a closure concurrency
library
and as an aside all the work and all my
slides are talking about the
closure the proper closure version of
these things not the closure script
version
just because that's the the context
which i'm working in
but corey sync is fundamentally about
the idea of creating these
concurrent threads that can communicate
asynchronously via channels
so it's all built to be concurrent so
you can have many threads all producing
items going into a channel
and on the opposite side many threads
kind of concurrently taking items out of
channels
the basic operators you have are first
you have go so anything inside of the go
will run in a separate concurrent thread
and it's not an os thread it's not a jvm
thread it's
a lighter weight mechanism it's part of
corey sync itself
you create channels for communicating
items by calling chan
and here i'm showing calling it with the
value three which will set
a max buffer size in that channel of
three
of three and then you can read and write
from channels
so greater than less than bang the
greater than bang
to a channel you can write a value x and
on the
the consuming side you can do less than
bang on a channel and that will produce
an item from the channel
so we take those operators and package
them up in
what i'll kind of call an asynchronous
function so here we've got a function f
which inside of it is using go threads
and channels to do something in this
case it starts three threads
one writes a value of one to a channel
the other one writes a value of two to
another channel
the third channel or the third thread
reads both those channels sums the
result
prints out the answer and this basic way
of packaging up
asynchronous code into a function is uh
the basis on which the library we built
runs so if you had a function like this
that did async
things then you could take this and you
could run it inside of our
what we call step machine so this shows
creating
a step machine in general you can give
it configuration parameters in this case
just takes all the defaults telling that
step machine
what function it needs to run and it
expects to have a function that
is doing core async stuff inside of it
and then this steps through it kind of
an arbitrary number of times in this
case 10 times
and for this stepping you can kind of
think of a debugger debugging your
regular code where you're stepping line
by line
but in this case in simplistic terms
what you can think of is doing is
it's stepping those threads from core
async called a core async call
and then after stepping it 10 times we
print out the state of the machine
so the state of the machine is
maintained as
as the code is running and it can be
produced as a closure data structure
and here you see it lists all the
threads all the channels what's in the
channels
it shows you what takes inputs are
blocked
this is kind of a broad use of the word
blocked it doesn't map precisely to
what you'll find if you talk about
parked or blocked threads inside of
quarry sync itself this is just a more
general term
but here you can see like what all the
threads are doing what the last thing
was done
basically you can see the state of that
overall machine
as it's running
so if we take it a step further and
change that original code to make use of
some features that aren't in core async
so here i'm adding uh actual string
labels to the two channels involved
channel one and channel two
and i'm giving labels to the worker
threads as well t1 t2 and t3
now flip a couple of options on the step
machine i'll tell it to keep track of
all the history of all the items that go
through channels
and of course you can't do that in
general but there's specific cases where
it might make sense to be able to do
that
and then i'll flip this other switch to
turn on state tracing for the machine
and what that will do is every time the
machine
the corey sync machine reaches a new
state it'll record
it'll capture the the state that that
map i showed before with all the threads
and channels and what the state is
so for the talk i made a little
throwaway visualization tool based on
this visualize library
and it reads through all those traces
and it can show you
you know what happened during the
execution of the machine and you can
step through it this is showing a
snapshot
at a certain point in time so all the
the rectangles here represent either
threads or channels
the arrows between them it analyzed like
the whole history of the trace
and figured out which threads
put to which channels and which threads
take from which channels
and so the the direction of those arrows
indicate that
the thread boxes they're labeled t1 and
t2 here you can see they're annotated
with
indicators saying if they're reading or
writing and what channel they're
currently reading or writing from
similarly the channels are annotated
here with
two vectors you see c1 and c2 both have
two vectors after their name
the first vector is all the items that
have ever passed through the channel and
the second
vector is are the items that are
currently in the channel
so basically what like my mental model
when i'm thinking about
this library is that these core async or
these asynchronous functions that use
core async operators
are like uh spring activated wind-up
toys
so you can think of having a toy and you
know it's got its exterior and then
inside of it there's various springs and
gears
and you can wind it up and then you can
let it run and as you're letting it run
you could imagine maybe just letting it
run a little bit you know just the turn
of one cog of one gear
or you kind of let it run till it winds
down that sort of thing
but in any event this blob of core async
code
is what's inside of that machine
so that's what i'm trying to render here
is that this border on the outside
represents the outside of that function
f that we were talking about
and this is just in general and then
inside of it there's various threads and
channels and things happening so there's
all this stuff going on
inside the machine which normally you
can't see
if you're just using straight up quarry
sync but this tool lets you
gain some visibility into what's inside
of there
and of course it's not all just what's
inside the machine these machines will
inevitably have
channels that allow you to interact with
it either on the input side or on the
output side
so this is my basic mental model that
i'm i have in mind with
the library that i'm talking about today
so like i said with the kind of wind-up
toy you can think of two ways of
letting it step or do its thing one is
just take the smallest increment
possible
and that's what step machine does if you
just say if you ask a machine to step
it will choose one of the threads and
let it run from the place it currently
is
to basically its next invocation of a
core async call
so it's kind of taking the smallest
increment it could from a core async
perspective
the other operation you could run is you
could ask it to step all
and what this does is you can think
about that wind-up machine it's like
just let it
do its thing until it stops and just
because it stops doesn't mean that it
can't do anything in the future you
might like touch it it
might start working again but at least
it's kind of quiet for the moment
and depending on what you're doing
either one of these modes might make
sense if you're more worried about the
internal operation
of how all your threads are working just
single stepping might make sense
but if you're more focused on kind of
the outside the interface of how you
work with it
it might make more sense to just kind of
let it run down between between steps
so both of these calls from the calling
threads perspective are asynchronous
that is the machine will just go off
and do its thing separate from you if
you want to sync up with it there's
corresponding calls to actually wait for
it to finish either a single step
or wait for it to wind completely down
so all these mechanisms i'm talking
about the basic idea is to turn this
core async execution from a black box
into a white box that you can see inside
of to
be able to further reason about what hap
what's happening what the current state
of that machine is
so these are all means of accomplishing
transparency
this is a list of all the operators that
are supported currently by the library
notably missing our transducers because
this work
predates that so it's not in there
here's an example of using another one
of the core async operator's partition
which will just divide up the items
coming through a channel in this case
into pairs
so we write in one two three negative
nine we get out pairs of those on the
output channel
and the point of this is that not only
can you use this
step async library for visualizing and
seeing what your code does but you can
also use it for understanding what the
built-in operators do as well
so in this example you know our code is
creating channel one
and then we create channel two by a
partition call and we just have one
thread t1
but if we look over here and visualize
what actually got created we see our t1
or c1
but then we see these additional
channels and threads that were created
by the partition operator itself
so we gain visibility into what those
the built-in operators
are doing
so other aspects of features that we
have
you might have a large network with lots
of channels and go
threads talking on them and you might
just be debugging part of it
so there's mechanisms in place to allow
you to send
items onto channels from outside of the
step machine
and from inside the step machine out
i just showed a simple case of a single
function f but you could break it down
in f and g and h
and compose those and run them under the
debugger and it would do what you expect
i didn't talk about all tests it's
basically like
c select for sockets where you can do
you can read from many channels
simultaneously and only one of them
that's available to be read from will
actually be read from
you can actually also use that in the
other direction so you can selectively
try to write to many channels at once
and only one will succeed
that's not supported today just because
it was a blind spot in my
kind of view of how i used core async
but there's no fundamental reason it
couldn't be extended to do that
it supports sliding and dropping buffers
which is a feature of core async
and then also supports this idea of
conditional break points so instead of
manually stepping it to where you want
you can register a breakpoint which is
basically a predicate function that will
be given the state of the machine
it can do whatever computation it wants
and say should it stop or not
so this is the case where you could
start it running and it will stop when
there's some important condition is met
that you want to to analyze better
so the basic idea of the library is it's
going to accomplish two things it's
going to make the execution of corey
sync code transparent
the other big item it takes on is trying
to make it deterministic
so core async by itself is
non-deterministic at its core it's about
starting up these concurrent
processes by being concurrent i mean the
definition is there's
a non-causal relationship there between
what's happening so that's
non-deterministic
in more concrete terms you can think of
many threads all
trying to take from a channel that's
empty and then when an item arrives
there's this
question of what thread does it go to
and that in core async is
non-deterministic by design
so i think of the all these issues as
kind of a scheduling problem so you've
got many threads that can be run
and you need to make a scheduler
decision about which one to run next
and of course in core async there's many
of them running like in parallel on your
machine
so what step async does is it enforces
them all to be run actually in series
and it'll make scheduling decisions
about which one to run next
so subject sync has this idea of you
know we'll plug in a scheduler
if you implement the closure protocol
you can plug it in it'll call you every
time it's got a decision to make and
then you decide what to do
it comes with two schedule or algorithm
algorithms
the first one by default is just a
simple deterministic scheduler
so if you think of the scheduling space
it's kind of this maze you have to walk
through it just kind of
says always go left kind of thing it
always does the same thing
the other one it has is that's provided
with it is a random
scheduler so here it uses a
pseudo-random number generator to
like generate a random number to inform
the decision about what scheduling
choice to make at each juncture
if you want to use that you instantiate
the step machine with a
random seed and then that will seed the
the execution path that will
exceed all the random numbers that are
generated to compute the execution path
and so if your code is deterministic
itself and that the only source of
non-determinism is core async use
then this will allow you to
deterministically run repeated
executions of the exact same random path
pseudo-random path by giving it the same
random seed
so this is an example where
we've got some core async code that
normally runs just fine
but there's actually a latent deadlock
hidden in this code so what this is
doing is
setting up two channels and then three
threads and if you look at it
kind of closely you'll see that worker
thread one and worker two
they're in this kind of embrace what's
the worker one writes to channel one
worker two receives a message from it
and on channel one and then writes to
channel two which w1 which worker one
receives so they're kind of talking to
each other
both these channels i've explicitly you
know made them with size 0 which they
would have by default but there's no
buffering there which means
the producers and consumers have to
rendezvous at
the time when an item is produced
if there's not an item there and you try
and taking from it try to take from it
you'll actually
wait there for an item to appear
similarly if you write
you'll wait for a consumer to appear or
a producer
a consumer to appear before your put
completes
so the point is w1 and w2 are kind of
locked in this embrace where they're
talking to each other
and that will work fine as long as w3
doesn't run before w1
so w3 is writing the channel one and
it's maybe it's kind of hard to see but
it'll actually cause it the machine to
deadlock if that happens before
before worker one completes so this
thread sleep in here is meant to
represent like some kind of long running
operation you would have in your code
so maybe that usually takes a while so
usually this code works fine
but there is a race condition between
worker 1 and worker 3 which
if worker 1 loses then the machine will
deadlock
so with code like this and with the
ability to provide these random seeds to
the scheduler
we can make use of an idea that i think
the genesis for me and this is
reid draper's talk at closure west last
year where he was talking about using
test check
to programmatically find race conditions
so this is using testcheck which is a
closure property based testing library
i'll kind of point out some of the
highlights here so what this is doing is
it's saying
it's asking testcheck to randomly
generate
a value r which we'll use as a random
seed to seed our step machine
and then we'll run that function that we
were just looking at
we'll ask the machine to step all the
way until it's done running
and then we'll look at the final output
value
output state that it arrives in there's
a token that's returned to either say
all that
to indicate why it has completed or why
it
the machine ran down either because all
the threads exited and there's nothing
else to do
or because all the threads are currently
blocked and they can't proceed
so this will pick 100 different random
numbers feed them in
and try to test that this property is
always held true that is the machine
always exits so if we run that
uh if you read through all this at the
bottom it tries to find the smallest
value that violates the property in this
case it found the value one will violate
the property
just to check to see if that's legit we
can run it through so if we run it
through with a random seed of zero we
see that it's all exited
we run it through with that random seed
of one which it indicated was a problem
we see oh everything's blocked which
means we've deadlocked
so this is pretty cool because what it
does it takes this concurrent code
it's non-deterministic it's going to be
running different paths at different
times
and it searches through all the
different scheduling paths to find one
that's problematic so it's
out there proactively trying to find
race conditions for us
and not only that but when it finds one
it gives us a value with which we can
then reproduce
the failing race condition sequence and
of course once we can reproduce the
problem we're well on our way to
you know getting it fixed uh if you want
to visualize what this looks like
this is the actual deadlock case so here
you see worker one is riding the channel
one
and then at the bottom worker two is
writing the channel two but there's
nobody reading from either of those
so it's it's going to sit there forever
i think i'm in good shape on time so any
questions at any time
uh raise your hand yes
if there's a deadlock
right so if there's a deadlock how does
the test finish well what this code does
is it asks
the um it seeds the value into the step
machine which is a value of one which
it's going to deadlock on
and then it says okay run until you
can't run anymore
and then this quiesce wait just it's
basically like we're waiting on a
promise for it to
to stop so internally the step machine
schedules all these threads
um makes scheduling decisions based on
that random seed and then the step
machine
is analyzing the state of all the
threads and what they're doing
and it determines that nothing else can
be run so when nothing else can be run
it returns from this quiet weight call
and says okay i'm done running there's
nothing else to do
so yes
so if you were using um core async
implementation it would be a real
deadlock but in this case you
your step machine can see inside and see
that
there's nothing else that can't happen
and it depends like often times your
query sync code is spawning go blocks
which are running asynchronously
so really you're not blocked as a caller
into that so the test wouldn't
necessarily block
it's just there's this machine out there
that you can't see into
that is in a state which is deadlocked
um
so yes um
so the way so this is starting up these
three threads
it's only going to run these threads
ever in sequence
so at some point it decides to run
this go block from basically you can
think of run from initiation
to the first core async call which is
here so it runs it
runs that at one point in the overall
sequence and nothing else is running at
the same time
so just however long that takes it takes
a second and then it finishes
yes that's right so the tick of the
machine is not per line of code it's
between core async calls essentially
yeah does this work with the
right yeah i've got a slide on that if
you can just wait a couple slides so
i'll press on now
okay another source of non-determinism
are timeouts so timeouts
if you call timeout 200 it makes a
channel which after 200 milliseconds
will produce a value which is
no but anyway you can you can treat
timeouts like channels but that's
another source of non-determinism right
because
you don't know the sequence which
timeouts are going to fire exactly the
way step async handles that
is none of the timeouts you in your code
ever fire
unless someone tells it to fire so
externally if you have one of these step
machines you can ask it what are all the
timeouts in the machine
and it'll give you a data structures
like this
and then if you want to programmatically
fire one of those under your control
you make a call into the step machine
and saying say fire this timeout now
so you can kind of get control of that
source of non-determinism
all right this is your your question so
this is the same example from the very
beginning but now i added on the
namespace information to show that we're
using these
closure core async operators so if you
want to use step by sync the way it
currently is what you do is you bring in
step async
version of these operators instead
if you do that then the function that
you write here with these if you don't
run it in a step machine
then it'll just delegate all that to
built-in core async and it'll operate
just like corey sync
but it gives you the function that you
produce like this is a function that
could be run inside of a step machine to
do all this kind of
controlled execution
so this leads to another way of
understanding what is step async it's an
alternate
implementation of a big chunk of core
async
in particular the channels and the
operators
once you have the primitives actually
most of the operators are just a really
straight port of the core async code
there's a few of them that do more
exotic things but many of them are just
a straight port
it's just built on putting and taking
from channels
it doesn't reimplement the go macro so
it just
intercepts all the calls to go and kind
of registers what's happening but then
it delegates all the work
to the go macro
so it's a different it's an alternate
implementation of the core async
operators
and where core async focuses on kind of
these non-functional parameters of
being very efficient and really enabling
parallelism
so not kind of like squashing the
opportunity from concurrency
step async instead focuses on doesn't
focus on those at all
in fact it's all serialized and it's
horribly inefficient
but it's deterministic and it's
transparent and you can control it
programmatically from the outside
so this is a glimpse into implementation
details
there's a def type which defines the
step machine itself
it has a bunch of values many of those
are refs
inside the operators it's coordinated
via the the closure stm
it's not necessary this isn't
necessarily the way you'd have to write
it it's just kind of stylistically the
way
i chose to do it
so to understand the implementation you
think about regular core async
you're making these go threads you're
making these channels
um those really they're not like unified
in any way
they're just objects on the heap that
happen to have references to each other
if you watch timothy baldridge's video
on um garbage collection with corey sink
he really kind of makes that point
so there's no sense in which these are
like centralized together and there's
anyone watching what's happening
it's just however they happen to be
laced together on the heap and that's
how you get garbage collection of all
these things
well step async doesn't follow that
model at all step async has this
centralized view
of everything that's happened within
that machine
it all gets pulled together in a central
place where it can keep track of these
are all the threads these are all the
channels
and then it really intercepts all the
corey sync calls that you make
and registers them in that central place
and then that central place
decides kind of spoon feeds out then you
know what to actually allow to run
next and this picture is kind of
horribly confusing but the main point is
there is this central place that's
that's tracking it all
which is not at all what you want like
in general like so i think like corey
sync is
i'm sure doing the right things in this
regard but there are some contexts
in which it's useful to be able to have
more visibility have more control
and so if those are things that are
useful to you then this is a possibility
for you
so this is an example that's a bit
different than the others that i showed
so what this is doing it's again one of
these asynchronous functions called
accumulator
this is actually taking in an input
channel and output channel which i
hadn't shown in the previous example
but you can do that
and what this does is it reads all the
values from the input channel expects
them to be numeric values
and it adds it keeps an accumulation of
all the sum of all the values that have
come
in so it reads a value in adds it to the
the
old sum and writes that sum out on the
output channel and then sits there in a
loop doing that
so if you ignore whatever magic core
async is doing you can think of
there's like a value on the stack
somewhere that's kind of accumulating
this state
and the point here is there's some state
inside of this function
that isn't like strictly part of the
core async state so it's not like a
thread or a channel or something like
that it's just some other
state of the machine the actual
virtual machine um so if we
run code like this and again flip some
switches here so i'll set this action
history to true
and i've elited some loaded some code
here that makes a little messy but
if you run this in a step machine then
you can do things like this so
here i'm showing i write in a value of 1
which causes a value of 1 to come out
on the output channel and then on the
input channel i put in a value of 2 so i
get 3 which is the sum of 1 and 2 and i
write in 3 which is the sum of
the previous value 3 and 3. so that's
just like what you would expect
but then again if all that code is
deterministic and the only source of
non-determinism is
um the query sync calls and if it's
purely functional there's not side
effects that are
bad to rerun then you can do things like
this you can take that step machine at
this point after we've written in one
two and three
and so we've got a value on a stack
somewhere saying um
there's a six in the current state of
the machine
we can ask it to go backwards so we kind
of say go back to the previous state
like go back a couple of steps
it turns out to be two based on the way
that like when you put something in
there's like
multiple steps to actually putting
something into a channel but anyway we
go back two steps and then ask for the
machine
that returns us a new machine we can ask
for that machine to kind of stop doing
whatever it's doing
which in this case you can kind of think
of it as going backwards
and then what we can do is we can write
in a new value so write in a value of 4
and so we get out a value of 7 now so
that's significant because
it's taken back a value that was written
in before
and gotten that code back to a state
that it was in
before and now put in a four and you get
out seven which means it's now
it's it's back in the state that it was
so it's as if we just did
one two and then four here the three has
kind of disappeared
so this is really just an experimental
feature in the code i just kind of did
it because
i could see that i could i don't know
that there's any
real practical value to it but it was it
was kind of fun to do
and um if you think about it you can
figure out what it's actually doing kind
of see behind the curtain here it's
not really stepping the machine
backwards rather it's
making a new machine and stepping
forwards from the beginning of time
until
you know just leaving off the last
couple of steps which gives you a new
machine that's
back in the state that the old machine
was in just before you did
the last two things
so that's what i have prepared you can
see the code up on
github it's code that we're currently
using
in the production code on one of our
projects
so there's what we're using is a thin
slice of the functionality that i showed
today so there's a thin
slice which i'm confident in and i think
is solid but as taken as a whole it's
really proof of concept code
so it needs some kind of care and
feeding
but like i said we are using it in
production code and the application
we're using it in
it's not for debugging at all but what
we're using it for is
we're using amazon simple workflow to
model distributed workflow executions
and the basic model with that is that
you have these concurrent workflow
executions that are running
and then they produce and they consume
these events
so it's a model that matches closely to
core async
and so on this project what we do is we
represent the logic of those workflow
executions
in core async so what you can think of
is
you know as the vision plays out you can
say you know we'll write
you know say a dozen workflows that all
work have to work together so we write
those as straight up core async code
and we can run those in a single jvm and
kind of get all the kinks worked out and
they're just talking to each other as
just
plain old core async
but then using step async and using some
additional machinery to kind of bridge
the gap between the distributed world
and
core async once we're happy that all our
logic is sound
we can then kind of promote those
workflows those uh core async threads
up into these workflow executions that
are now running in a distributed fashion
out on amazon cluster
uh under amazon's simple workflow and so
step async is critical in that role
because what happens is
there might be a workflow running on a
given machine so it's receiving events
and it's making decisions producing
output events
and for whatever reason just you can
imagine now we need to move that to
another machine
and so when we go to move that to
another machine the ability for us to
programmatically
like access the state of that machine
and programmatically like recreate the
state of that machine on another
host is what enables us to
kind of maintain this illusion that
these things
are just running in process when they're
actually kind of being time sliced
across
hosts
so that's all i have prepared thank you
and
yeah have time for questions
oh thank you um
really a data representation of that
execution path in the end
do you support direct submission of data
to drive
this engine it's kind of driving
completely data i want to write
anymore i just want to generate data
that
so the question was can you just drive
it with data not with channels
now you have to use the querysync api or
the api that i've shown
i'm not i guess i'm not sure what you're
asking
you're printing it right so just inject
that in like say this is my current
state i'm in this state now run from
there
you know an operation into leaving right
i just want to give you that i don't
want to
wait for some random path to find it i
want to say
this i see
so certainly for the parts that
are being explicitly tracked by the step
machine that is the channels the threads
listeners i mean there's certainly no
reason you can't inject those things in
the problem is there are actual
there's actual code somewhere that has
go blocks it's in the current state
and that state is not represented inside
of the step machine but it's relying on
there being actual go block somewhere
that the cust that the user wrote that
are in a certain state
and without stepping through all the
states to get them in the right place
then i don't see a path with the way it
is right now to get to make that happen
um obviously one place you want to take
chorusing proper is to have
better visibility and sort of the
determinism part of this is something
that is going to have performance
impacts and
not something you want to identify for
anything but
visibility constructs and monitoring
stuff
is something they're looking to do you
have ideas about what you
find desirable in that space
right well i didn't show it i did this
really crude ui
which just kind of renders these things
i had a kind of a pseudo spec for like a
real ai that would show your ui that
would show you
these are the threads these are the
channels here's how they're
interconnected and now to kind of
interactively explore it to see the
current state
and then obviously on the monitoring
side like i said you can see you can
like
emit information saying you know what
state all these different things are in
i haven't done work beyond that though
i don't know if that answers your
question yep
oh was that a statement or a question
oh yeah
yeah uh there was that example that i
showed that i think is
what you're talking about where we're
using testcheck to kind of run through
the different paths to find
um a deadlock but are you saying do like
analysis to determine when there will be
deadlock
if you search through the decisions
you might find more effective than just
supplying different random seeds
i see yeah it's where you try to reason
about it and get it into a certain state
maybe
no i have not that sounds interesting
and i guess rich to one of your points
about
you wouldn't want the non-deter the yeah
the non-determinism in cory sync
like i totally see that for let's say
most use cases or almost all use cases
i think there are use cases where
that is what you want um like that's
what we want for
that simple workflow example that i
described we the the performance of it
is absolutely irrelevant it's
can we control the execution and is it
deterministic and so that's production
code where that's how we want it to
behave and
when i published the synopsis of this
talk i was contacted by an outfit that's
doing the same thing for simulation
so the reason corey sync is the
fundamental abstraction or the the means
of describing their simulation
and they want to be able to control that
from the outside to say let's play it a
little bit further let's go back let's
go forward kind of thing
and so again there it's not the raw
performance of how fast it goes but it's
expressing their logic with those
primitives and then running it in a
controlled deterministic fashion
no
it seems like it wouldn't be that hard i
mean closure script is already running
in this kind of serialized fashion but i
guess that's a total
like tangential issue um i haven't done
anything with closure script
uh it doesn't strike me on the surface
as being something that's hard for any
reason i just haven't done anything with
it
yeah um when you step to a point where
the only thing is if every thread is
blocked
on like a timeout is your step ball
and then complete the timeout
so the question is if you do the step
ball and all the threads are waiting on
a timeout
what happens what happens is if you say
step all and it sees that all of them
are waiting on a timeout
that's just as if they're waiting on a
regular channel and it says oh they're
all
waiting and there's no input for them
and there's no one but that will ever
come to them unless someone
programmatically calls that thing to
make the timeouts fire
so yeah
yeah absolutely
uh scott okay i'm trying to crack what
you said at the end where you
you use step async in a mode in
production where you're not
you're not using it to step but rather
to
publish a diagram like this that enables
you to
promote your workflow to amazon's
infrastructure is that
correct um that's not the way i would
say it so what we're doing
is
so we need some logic to run for a
workflow and that's represented in core
async code
so we get a call for a workflow we fire
up one of these machines
we get it to the state we want and then
we give it some input
say this is new input that's arrived i
want you to tell me what to do
i think of it like the matrix so you got
people and people know how to interact
with each other their brains they take
an input they produce output
but the matrix they wired up these
people's brains and they just like
stimulate it with stuff and then kind of
got something out i guess they got heat
out but
um so i think of it like that you've got
this cor this asynchronous machine which
is like a person
it can take input and it does things but
we're putting it in
this matrix where we just wire it up and
we say here's your reality here's the
events have happened to you
and ignore whatever you do but now
here's the new event drop in the new
event
and whatever it does it decides oh this
is what this is my output this is an
action i would like to take
and then we take that and we register
that with simple workflow saying this is
what
this workflow should do now and um
one of the things we do since we have
programmatic control of it we can do
things like
ask that machine when it's done running
which is a problem with corey sync if
you have some core async code and you
call into it
like just a that one of those functions
f that does corey sync things
how do you know when it's done you don't
right unless you do something explicit
to allow it to communicate out to you
if you just fire it up and it runs you
don't know if it's ever produced its
last event that it's going to produce
so this gives us i mean you can solve
that problem you can have like an output
channel and it writes to the output
channel and closes it when it's done and
you see the close so you know it's done
but this allows us to just more
generally like fire up the code and let
it run for a while
and it doesn't have to do anything
explicit to tell us when it's done
we can programmatically look at it and
see that it's done
i think i still have time if there's
more you get a question
so have you thought about applying
property-based testing to
a machine and then um like having
one of your uh having an endearing
function fire off at every tick
and assert
no but you yeah obviously you could do
that yeah
library that's um um i know
in the in the
testing set for four async there's
a macro that just runs it one step
inside of the click so it does the
transform into the
into the state machine and it just runs
that state machine one step
um is there a reason that you just focus
on the call back out to the async stuff
as opposed to just
it seems like you could go straight to a
full-blown debugger
just doing i mean you wouldn't be able
to survive a call into another function
but you would everything that was inside
that state machine
i'm not familiar with the mechanism you
described it's entirely possible that if
i knew about it i should have would have
used it
um i will say that recently i got to see
rich's talk for mural closure where he's
talking about the implementation of
channels
and it's a great talk and it would have
been good for me to watch that before i
did this
um because it obviously has you know
very precise thinking about some of the
invariants that need to hold while
you're while you're doing this but
uh if you're interested in this kind of
thing i definitely recommend that
i think we're out of time is that right
all right i think we're out of time i'm
happy to take questions down here
afterwards
thank you